if you keep on doing what you've been
doing you're going to keep on getting
what you've been getting you got to
change performance now before you can
change performance you got to change
your thinking but before you can change
your thinking you've got to change what
goes into your mind I don't care how
positive I got for example I could not
whip a boxing champion or play
basketball for an NBA basketball team or
football for an NFL team positive
thinking won't let you do anything but
it will let you do everything better
than negative thinking will zig Ziggler
was one of the world's most popular
motivational speakers Ziggler was one of
12 children raised by a widowed mother
during the Great Depression he wrote
over 25 books including see you at the
top and inspired millions of people
around the world in this exclusive
training Ziggler shares with us the
power of positive thinking how to
reprogram your mind and how to improve
every aspect of your life special thanks
to the Ziggler family for partnering
with us to release this exclusive
content on our YouTube channel
enjoy yes life can be fun it certainly
can be exciting as a matter of fact I
believe that you were born to win
unfortunately too many people have been
conditioned to lose the truth of the
matter though is the fact that I believe
you can be number one now that doesn't
mean I believe that everybody can be the
biggest and the fastest and the
strongest and the smartest but I believe
when you get up in the morning and look
in that mirror and say today I'm going
to do my very best and then that day you
do your best and that evening you look
back in the mirror and say today I did
my best I believe you are number one our
basic problem in our society today is a
tremendous amount of negative input in
our minds you see the truth of the
matter is you are are what you are and
you're where you are because of what has
gone into your mind and you can change
what you are and change Where You Are by
changing what goes into your mind the
problem is as I indicated we have too
much of the negative input for example
we talk about the terrible twos when in
reality they're the terrific twos the
tremendous threes the Fantastic Fours
The Fabulous fives the super sixes The
Sensational sevens actually you could
take three babies one born in Chicago
Illinois one born in Shanghai China the
other born in the upper Amazon and you
raise those babies there and the baby
born in China because of the input will
grow up to be a communist the baby born
in the upper Amazon and raised there
because of the input will believe in
head hunters and Witchcraft and voodo
and that sort of thing now the baby born
in Chicago and raised there is obviously
going to grow up leaving in the Chicago
Bears that's right that input does make
such a tremendous difference but input
too often as I said is negative I was in
a cafeteria and a little girl in front
of us was crying a grandmotherly type
lady leaned down and said what's the
matter honey and her Daddy spoke up and
said she's mean that's what she just
plain mean I was up in Nashville
Tennesse on the way down to the gate to
catch a plane passed a lady and a little
5-year-old boy and as I was walking past
the little guy was dragging his heels
and the mother turned to him and said
come on stupid we're going to miss the
plane now what does that do to that
child what does it do to the image of
the child and the optimism and
enthusiasm of the child I think you know
the answer my friend Bill gas tells me
that over 90% of the people in our
prisons today and jails were repeatedly
told by their parents one of these days
you're going to grow up
and go to jail he was sharing with me
that at one of their Association
meetings or revivals actually there in a
prison he and Jim glass the champion
catcher for the world's champion Kansas
City Royals were talking and as they
were chatting uh Jim sunberg who had
been told when he was three years old
down in Stockton California by his dad
one of these days son you're going to
grow up and be a great major lead
catcher he told him that over and over
and Bill and Jim were talking and Jim
just shared with Bill you know I'm sure
glad that when I was a child that my dad
told me that when I grew up I was going
to be a world's champion catcher because
I am exactly where he said I was going
to be and an incarcerated man standing
close by quietly but rather sadly said
well you know I'm exactly where my dad
told me I was going to be you see that
input does make a dramatic difference
the good news is very simple you do have
some of every single quality which we've
identified but let me tell you something
to think about if you had a million
dollars in the bank you would never
write a check on it if you did not know
the money was in the bank but the the
moment you discovered it was there
that's when the local economy would take
a giant leap forward and I've discovered
that everybody everywhere seems to want
exactly the same thing everybody wants
to be happy everybody wants to be
healthy they want to be at least
reasonably prosperous they want to be
secure they want to have friends and
they want to have peace of mind now
think with me on this please if those
are the things that you want doesn't it
make sense to take an inventory and see
what you youve got and when you take
that inventory and discover what you've
got if you discover that it's short of
what you want then surely it makes sense
to you to discover and explore how you
got what you got and what you're going
to discover is this you've gotten the
things you've gotten based on your
performance now the possible exception
to that is money occasionally someone
inherits that and I don't depend on it
but it it can happen all of the other
things are based on your performance so
logically if you want to change what
you've got does it it make sense that
you've got to change your performance
because you see in the simplest term
posses if you keep on doing what you've
been doing you going to keep on getting
what you've been getting you got to
change performance now before you can
change performance you got to change
your thinking because you see you're
thinking regardless of what you do has a
dramatic impact on that performance but
before you can change your thinking
you've got to change what goes into your
mind and now we're back where we started
you're what you are and where you are
because of what's going into your mind
and you can change what you are you can
change Where You Are by changing what
goes into your mind now I have in my
hands a most unusual coin here it is a
piece of gold it's a gold coin therefore
customade especially for me by a close
friend as you can see on this side
there's the ARA going up see you at the
tops what it's really saying if you'll
also notice I have in my other hand
another coin it's a dime now these two
coins if they're placed at the bottom of
the ocean have exactly the same value
that is nothing because they're not
being used when you bring them to the
surface however this gold coin is worth
several hundred whereas this one is
still worth the dime now the difference
really is what's in the coins but the
fact that we've now brought them to the
surface to use them in your own life all
of the qualities and values you have
unless you bring them to the surface and
use them they really won't have that
value now on the other side of this
custombuilt coin we have a rather unique
uh little thing if you look very
carefully you can read it says
Tui T and since the coin itself is Round
And since this is a to it this means
this literally is a round to it many
times I've had people say to me well I'm
going to do something just as soon as I
get a round to it hey there it's Mark
Tim with the Ziggler family and I sure
hope you're enjoying the video from my
mentor the legendary Zig Ziggler because
you're part of Evan's audience we want
to give you a special bonus it's a cool
little book called the little book of
big quotes packed with awesome content
this book is free just for you check out
the description below and it's yours all
righty let's get you back to Zig Zig
you've stressed the importance of input
and it really makes sense but where do
we get the right kind of positive input
well basically uh Jim we have a number
of sources the associates the people
we're with and around certainly have an
input the people we work with our
families uh all of these have inputs now
the question is is it the correct input
a lot of times unfortunately the answer
to that is no so to compensate for the
negative input we have to deliberately
seek the positive input by that I mean
we simply need to read the good books
the optimistic positive thinking uh
powerful uh inputs into our mind we need
to listen to those recordings as we are
driving to and from the car can make a
marvelous traveling educational
institution we need to listen while
we're washing dishes are weeding the
flower bed we can do those things when
we are well shaving or applying makeup
that's where we need to have that
positive input who are some of the
people or kinds of people people that
have used the input you're talking about
well I once made the statement that I
had never known a self-made millionaire
in the world of selling who did not have
and use motivational input and have his
own cassette recorder uh I'm certain
that uh that might not be true today uh
because of the chains in the economy but
by and large successful people listen I
know HL hunt for example example listen
until after he was 80 years old U Mary
Kay Ash told me that she never started
her car until she first made certain
that she had a motivational or
educational recording in the car Alan
Bean uh one of the astronauts who walked
on the moon told me that the astronauts
were listening to motivational
recordings going back and forth from the
Moon and I'm obviously pleased to be
able to say that at least some of the
recordings they were listening to were
fantastic
Z I heard you relate a story that I
thought was really fascinating about a
man by the name of Tom Hartman why don't
you tell us about Tom that's probably
the most remarkable story in many ways
because in every area of his life uh Tom
needed help he was financially bankrupt
he was spiritually bankrupt he was
physically bankrupt he was socially
bankrupt and that might sound like a
harsh word uh but when I say bankrupt I
at least mean he was very in short
supply Tom had a 63 and 1/2 in waistline
weighed 406 lbs by his own admission uh
kind of had to maneuver in order to get
eating money each week he is coming off
a devastating divorce had not been in
church in a number of years
educationally was uh stamed he was going
to college part-time but it was just to
fill his time he got involved in
listening to my set of tapes and as Tom
said he said Z I have listened to them
so many times particularly the one on
self image that I can quote you verba
them he said I bet I've listened to that
one over 500 times and the other tapes
over a hundred times well it didn't
happen over night but repetition is the
mother of learning and we need to be
convinced that yes we can do these
things so to kind of round up the story
uh Tom Hartman today weighs in the
vicinity of 200 pounds which is
acceptable because he's over 6 feet tall
he went back to college he got his
degree in Psychology graduated Magnum L
and is working on his doctrate has his
own business and is happier actually
than I've ever seen Tom before he's
teaching a Sunday school class his
personal life his family life his
business life his spiritual life they've
all come together now I want to stress
this was not an easy thing it involved
many many months for Tom to do all of
these things and I'll be the first to
admit that this is an extreme example
but we have literally hundreds even
thousands of examples where when people
changed the input in their mind they
dramatically altered all facets of their
life Wow Zig that is really motivating
but I guess the question that follows is
is motivation permanent well the answer
to that Jim is no uh motivation is not
permanent but then neither is bathing
but it is something which we should do
very regularly for that matter eating is
not permanent but it's something we've
got to do every day now it'd be absurd
to think that you could hear one
positive speech or read one positive
book and go through the rest of your
life completely motivated it's something
you work at every day Zig some people
say that it's easy I've heard speakers
say that with a positive attitude you
can do anything how do you respond to
that I'd say right off the top of my
head that's
insane uh I don't care how positive I
got for example I could not whip a
boxing champion or play basketball for
an NBA basketball team or football for
an NFL team I don't care how positive I
got I couldn't run General Motors with
just positive thinking I couldn't even
take your appendix out with just
positive thinking no positive thinking
won't let you do anything
but it will let you do everything better
than negative thinking will I'll tell
you exactly what positive thinking will
let you do it will let you use the
Ability which you have and when you use
what you've got my friend that is
sufficient to improve dramatically every
phase of your life now Zig you and the
audience went on to list 27 success
qualities but in the interest of time
how about summarizing what you're
getting at with that activity well what
we were doing there is finding out from
them obviously what's necessary in their
opinion to be successful and we then ask
a question after we had listed all 27 of
those qualities and that question was
are these attitudes or are they skills
and we discovered that all 27 of them
actually involved attitude then I asked
the question well how many of you had a
course in school which taught you how to
develop these attitudes and as is my
custom all over the country when I ask
that question less than 1% of them held
up their hands and that kind of sounds
like an indictment on the educational
system but I went ahead to point out to
them that the average student in America
Goes to School 5 days a week 180 days a
year 6 hours a day that means they're in
school 1,080 hours but they're 8,700 60
hours in a year so what that means is
that they're at home a little over a th
hours they're in uh what that really
means then is that they're in school a
little over a th000 hours they at home
over
7,600 hours and Mom and Dad have had the
child over
40,000 hours before the teachers ever
see them then ask the audience if they
didn't think that parents should accept
just a little bit of the responsibility
so I'm not inditing the educational
system what I'm saying is we've got a
societal problem and all of us therefore
as part of society must accept our share
of the
responsibility and then I kind of ask
him the question how many of you believe
uh that if these qualities were taught
at home and then
reinforced uh in school that would' have
a better America and you can well
imagine they all responded
enthusiastically to that because you see
when a child or an individual develops
honesty car and integrity and faith and
love and loyalty and dependability and
enthusiasm and a positive mental
attitude when they develop all of those
including a trust and loyalty and what
have you that individual will be
accepted in any society anywhere they
can get any school any college any job
market will be open to them in other
words here is a rare individual and the
exciting part came when I pointed out
that actually every single person has
some of all of these qualities to watch
another amazing Zig Ziggler video check
it out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there for 24 years of my
adult life I weighed well over 200 lb I
say by choice because you see I have
never accidentally eaten anything